alright this is a pepper panic saga
level 90 4 walkthrough tutorial it goes
along with our pepper panic tips level
94 guide Justin help show you how to
apply the tips and i'm going to play to
the level and complete it and explain
why I make what I make the decisions
that I may we need to clear out the ice
on the left so we're going to make shock
wave matches to get rid of that over
there and we have an else set up in the
beginning so that's a good match we
don't have another one set up so we'll
just clear out some space and hope we
get it hopefully we'll get a drop we do
have the gap at the top there but we
don't really want to shoot the free
purple one that we have here we could
make a tee but that's not going to help
much so we'll make the will move the red
one down and we'll make two for pepper
matches and that will give us a little
free up and give us a match on a purple
right there
now we have another L at the tops and
we'll go ahead and take that and we have
when you have red and blue like two of
the same color in the middle like this
that blocks any chance you have of
making a gap so I usually just clear
those out when I don't have a match
that's going to make a shockwave and
whenever you have Purple's where you can
match them like that you want to match
them together right away it usually
causes more purple to fall right onto
the board so that gets you closer to
your goal of exploding one then you saw
there that the purple fell like right
afterwards so now we can explode this
purple pepper here and that will open up
the board hopefully
okay it didn't in the next to start a
panic it usually does but we have 11
moves left so that's pretty good we
don't have any shock waves then we can
hit the statues with so we'll go ahead
and explode this purple pepper at the
bottom and then I'll open up the middle
we we want to hopefully hit one of these
top statues statues on the top row
because when those are gone that allows
for another pepper to fall into place
and it's pretty hard to complete it if
you don't do that early so when
everything falls into place you're going
to want to look around and see if you
have any setups that where you can hit
one of these statues I don't right now
so I'm going to try to rearrange things
you have the Getty when you have gaps
like that one you know you want to hope
that to get a shock wave to go over
there which we did
and just clearing out space now we have
the four pepper match where we can get
rid of that statue so that's the kind of
thing we want to do now you can see we
have a purple red and a blue over there
so if we explode any one of those colors
it'll get damage to the statue now we
have a gap for the red on the top
it almost you better to explode some
peppers because we have two blue ones
sitting in there so I'm just going to go
ahead and explode the blue and then I'll
clear out some more of the statues now
where the chain reaction starts that's
probably going to get all of them except
for one so we'll just have one statue
left to take out since they have hits on
them already you only have to get one
one hand on them to get them to explode
so they disappear pretty fast didn't get
a great setup here we don't have any
shock waves that we can shoot at the
last statue so we do have a little bit
of group growth on the purple so i guess
i guess here we want to try to get a
chain reaction with perfectly only have
three moves so it's going to be tough
but there's no shock waves or anything
to set up a shock wave so in the middle
we can get a little bit of we can set up
the explosion with the purple and two
matches so i'm going to go ahead and do
that now it didn't start a chain
reaction and it didn't set up anything
for a shock wave so we do have some
grown purple ones down here on the right
so we're basically going to match the
red and hope that another purple one
falls in and we get an explosion and as
you can see it did now a couple things
to keep in mind when stuff like that i
mean there's only a couple colors on the
board so your chances are good to get a
match that you need to for the color you
need to fall into place and sometimes
those little things as you can see there
are the things that will actually help
you get past it finally it's a difficult
level it took this video took quite a
few tries so hang in there and just try
to make those little choices when you
can hope this helps make sure you like
like the video if it was helpful
share it with your friends so that they
can get past it too if you have any
questions leave a comment if you'd like
to see another video with commentary
like this just leave a comment for us on
our site and we'll try to get we're made
for you and we'll have new videos coming
soon so thanks